[music] It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God. [singing and music]
>> Muslim. We got We got a D here. He gives
dollar.
>> You mind if I record this?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Come over to me.
>> Oh, no.
>> Sorry. Um, so we can take this. Oh,
yeah. You're IP. You need You need to be
busy
>> over here. We want everybody to get
ahead.
>> Okay, there we go. All right, so this
this one should be an easy one. Okay, so
what you think, brother?
>> So the first I'm going to give y'all
three points.
>> All right,
>> the first point is how Jesus prayed.
>> Okay,
>> if we look at today's society, we look
at how Christians pray and look how
Muslims pray. It states in the Bible
that you obviously know too that Jesus
prayed with his head down. Okay.
>> And that basically how Muslims pray
nowadays.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> The second point is
>> that's point one. Cool.
>> Second point is it's simple but it's
like if y'all really Jesus believers
y'all do it. It's not eating pork.
>> Okay.
>> States in the Bible that Jesus never ate
pork.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> The third one is it's a good point that
Jesus taught pure monotheism.
>> Okay. That's a good point. So us to us
to us and to me the trinity doesn't make
sense logically.
>> All right.
>> I don't think if the father is God and
father is the son you know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The trinity.
>> Yeah. And in the uh Quran Jesus is
stated more than Muhammad.
>> He is. That's true.
>> He's one of the most beloved prophets.
That's true.
>> And we love him like dearly.
>> Yeah. We think that he was not he was
not basically executed.
>> Yeah. He wasn't crucified. He was saved
by Allah, right?
>> He was saved by Allah and he was uh
>> raised up
>> raised up to heaven.
>> We believe that he's going to come back
at the end of times to fight the
Antichrist.
>> That's right. Okay.
>> It's like we have a similar kind of
belief.
>> Yeah, that's true. We do have a lot of
similarities. That's that's what we can
relate to.
>> So, all right, let's do one point at a
time. You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, first point was is that Jesus
prayed with his head to the ground.
That's how Muslims pray. And so
therefore, that shows that he's a
Muslim. Whoa. Oh,
>> [__]
>> You You all right, bro?
>> You good?
>> You guys see me coming?
>> Come on. Come on. Let's go out the
street.
>> Keep going, brother.
[snorts]
>> I'm sure.
>> You sure?
Jeez.
>> What the
>> They look like it.
>> You sure?
>> I apologize.
Okay.
>> That's insane, man.
He looked like he did that on purpose
low key
>> cuz he could have stopped earlier, bro.
>> Next time stop earlier.
>> You
okay? He got back up though. That's
good.
He He got back up. Okay. All right, man.
Jeez. All right. Back to uh back back to
the back to the you know goodness
gracious. That's insane. All right. So,
he prayed with his head to the ground.
That's how Muslims pray. All right. All
right. So, let me uh let me ask you
this. Let's say I prayed with my head to
the ground. All right. But I'm praying
to a statue that I made. Would you say
that I'm a Muslim?
>> No.
>> No. Why not?
>> It shows that you humble yourself to
another being, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> But but does that does that make me a
Muslim?
>> It doesn't.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, it shows that you're
humbling yourself to another thing. It
doesn't have to be true, but you're
humbling yourself.
>> I got you. So, if I humble myself to the
wrong thing,
>> you go. If I h if I humble myself to
something that is not the true God, then
I'm not a Muslim. Right? Okay. So, when
we look at what Jesus prostrated when he
prostrated to, we got to make sure that
he's prostrating to the same God that uh
that Islam is preaching about, you know.
Make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So when uh let me ask you this. Uh
does Allah have any sons, any daughters?
It states
>> he doesn't beg nor is he begotten. Good
stuff. Okay. So he has no children.
Right. So in the verse where Jesus
prostrates, it says this. He says he
went
>> he went a little further. Huh? Are you
looking at for your
>> No, I think I had that verse.
>> Okay, good. Yeah, it's Matthew 26:39. It
says, "Going a little further, Jesus
fell to the ground with his face on the
ground and and he prayed, saying,
>> "Father, if it be possible, let this cup
pass from me, but not my will, let your
will be done." Right? So, you know the
point I'm about to hit, huh? He called
God his father.
>> Yeah. That's he's like he's kind of
differentiating himself for us. We
believe Jesus like, "No, we believe if
you're a God,
>> we believe you're perfect. You're
almighty. You don't need to have a son."
>> Sure. You don't. It's like we believe
you're perfect.
>> And
>> so if Jesus if Jesus taught that God has
a son, then he's not a Muslim, right?
>> No. What can you
>> We don't believe. We believe that the
Bible was corrupted and they stated that
>> God has a son.
>> I thought you would say that. So here
here's the point about that is that the
verse the [laughter]
>> the verse you're so the verse you talked
about where Jesus said is prostrates in
the Bible that same verse says that he
prostrated to his father.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> So if you're going to say that the
Bible's corrupt, then you're going to
have to say that the part that says he
prostrated is corrupt. That's no. We
believe uh the Bible uh it was corrupted
but not everything in it
>> is corrupted because we believe the
Bible
>> at once at a time it was a true word of
God.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh we believe like people that came
and they started editing stuff and they
started adding new stuff.
>> So they didn't edit the part where he
prostrated.
>> We don't know why edit. God knows.
>> So then how do you know that that the
where it says he prostrated is correct?
We just know we just know that it's
simple if we compare it with Quran
>> and if that's like has no contradictions
we believe and if you want to think if
that has no contradictions that have
that has it's a better source
>> but the so this is this is my problem
okay so because I'm hearing you out I'm
listening but the the things that don't
connect for me is is that you said that
Jesus prayed like a Muslim Right? And
you got that from the Bible. You didn't
get that from the Quran. You quoted the
Bible for that. When we look at what the
Bible says in which he prostrated when
he fell to the ground, it says he prayed
to his father, which is something the
Muslim can't do. Right? So, if we use
that same verse you're talking about, it
shows Jesus is not a Muslim. But then
you're saying, well, that verse is
corrupted. That's been tampered with.
Right?
>> We're not talking about that. We're not
saying that him praying to the father.
We're just saying how he prayed.
>> But how do you know who? See,
>> he fell to the ground. That's how. And
>> that's true. But remember again, I said
if I fall to the ground and pray, it
doesn't mean I'm a Muslim cuz I could be
praying to the wrong thing, right?
>> Yeah. But you're still humbling
yourself. And I have him. Yeah. And
Jesus, I don't think if he's God, he
doesn't need to have to humble.
>> Let's let's let's let's forget the Jesus
is God part for a second. Just talk
about what Jesus believed. Okay. We know
he prayed. We know he worshiped the
father. And so if he's what he's
humbling himself to matters. Would you
agree?
>> Yeah.
>> So if he's humbling himself to something
that is oppo opposite to what the Quran
says, then he can't be a Muslim, right?
If I humble myself to the car, just cuz
I humble myself, that's that's wrong.
I'm committing sherk, right? If I humble
myself to the car or to any of you guys,
I'm committing sherk.
>> No, but probably at those times at that
time, everyone they prayed with their
head on the ground cuz that's how they
all used to pray. But it doesn't mean
that uh everyone in general uh they
couldn't
>> [laughter]
>> We don't uh we don't necessarily every
we don't necessarily say everything is
wrong or everything is right
>> cuz
>> we as Muslims only God knows how much
has been corrupted
>> and we can only tell you based on
comparing what the Quran teaches
>> and that's how we can compare you know
what we know.
>> So then how do you know that Jesus how
do you know how Jesus prayed
>> based on everything? Based on
>> based on what exactly? evidence we like
it says in the Quran since the Quran
logically it's the best source of text
>> I I'm with you where in the Quran does
it say that Jesus prayed with his head
to the ground
>> shows that Jesus Yeah probably I
probably can pull up a verse
>> All right we have one more minute we
have Arabic school
>> okay
>> there is like there's probably
>> I'm I'm going to save you some time cuz
I know you don't have much it doesn't
exist
>> no but it shows that it doesn't say how
he prayed, but it tells us what he did.
Basically,
>> it it does it tells you it tells you he
prayed, right? But you're talking about
how he prayed that that's what makes him
a Muslim.
>> No, we didn't say that. That's
>> Yeah, you said like praying praying his
head to the ground.
>> No, no, I probably meant that's we met
that he shared character I mean same
like
>> similarities with Muslims with Muslim.
>> So, but so so do I. Like, for example, I
I pray, you pray, Muslims pray, I pray,
Christians pray. That doesn't make us
Muslims the same thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So how So look, here's my point.
Jesus having, let's say, even having
some similarities to you, it doesn't
make him a Muslim. What you're going to
have to do is show that Jesus prayed to
and believed in the same God that you
believe in as a Muslim. If he taught
anything else, then he's not a Muslim.
Could you agree with that?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But we believe
>> we believe I know. I just want to talk
about the Trinity cuz you
>> want to talk about the Trinity.
>> It makes no sense. I'm I'm just saying.
>> Yeah. But but this doesn't we got to
pause here cuz that's that's a huge
jump, you know. This isn't Look,
brother, if if we could get past this,
>> I I promise you we could talk. If How
long is your school? How long is your
class?
>> Oh, it's after hours.
>> It's after the us.
>> After 5. Okay.
>> Dang. Wait. So, wait. When does class
start?
>> Right now.
>> It starts. So, it's like 3 hours.
>> Yeah.
>> Jeez.
>> Okay. Well, look. Um, we might be We'll
see. We might be around if you guys
could if we're still around and you guys
come back and you guys come out, we
could talk about the chiny, but we got
to finish this. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Please be careful crossing
the street, guys.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait,
>> cuz there's there's there's trucks, man.
>> Yeah, he said 5 minutes.
>> Okay, y'all be safe. Okay. Yeah,
>> be safe crossing and everything cuz
they're crazy out here obviously.
Goodness gracious.
>> Um,
>> but yeah, if you guys man class is 3
hours, that's
>> that shows how inspired we are and how
the connection of our religion to Islam
is. We want to learn more about it
because it doesn't hurt to know more.
Not
>> 100%. So
>> that's why I looked into the Bible and
that's why I looked in Islam. I mean,
and I see
>> I I want you to look more into it,
brother, because from what from what I'm
hearing, you you know some stuff, which
is good. But, uh, I could tell that you
you haven't you haven't read the Bible
yourself, but like you've kind of heard
talking points on it, you know, is am I
am I accurate in that? No, there's to
some extent, but I just like if I'm
reading to the Bible and there's or
contradictions like I do not want to
>> that would mean that the Quran is making
a mistake cuz it says the Bible is true.
>> No, it said never says the Bible's true.
It said at a time it was true.
>> It never says that.
>> No, yeah, exactly. You just said that.
>> No, it never says at a time. It says
it's true. Period.
>> Okay. But yeah, at a time it was true
until people came.
>> And the Quran never says people
corrupted the books.
>> It did. It says it says people lie about
them. Nope. It's because there's
multiple to the Torah to the Bible.
This how you talking about how the Jews
corrupted the uh the Torah.
>> It doesn't say that.
>> What What verse is this?
>> Uh
uh can you uh translate what you were
saying in English for me? I don't know
that
>> all I all I understood was Torah.
[laughter]
>> I did not have the official.
>> Okay, it's all right. But I'm just
saying like
>> we we we said that Bible
>> at a time it was true
>> but you know Paul after all
>> no you know after all of them came you
know
>> at that time I'm not saying necessarily
I'm just saying at that time that's when
>> so then why does the Quran say that the
Torah and the Gospel are true even in
Muhammad's time?
>> Time is true.
>> So even in Muhammad's time is true.
>> No never said Muhammad's time. Yeah, he
cuz look he said look it says in chapter
Sur Bakar ayia 41 it says believe in
what we have sent down confirming that
which is with you. So the scriptures the
Jews and Christians have with them the
Quran says the truth
>> it could have been talking about it
could have been he could have sent that
verse down to another [music] like
another people.
>> So so so then another people had the
true scriptures is what you're saying.
>> Yeah it could that's good. No, not uh
the Quran, but we're just saying he
could have set that down and the Quran
just quoted it again.
>> All right, you got to go. All right, see
you guys, man. Thanks for talking to us,
man. Please be safe. It was so nice
meeting you, man.
>> Don't hurt nobody.
>> I like the shades, man. You look cool.
>> I got one question.
>> Sure.
>> If if Jesus prays to the father, then
why do you guys pray to him?
>> Cuz he told us to pray to him as well.
So Jesus says that he when he goes to
the father, he says we can ask him
anything in our in his name and he'll
answer it for us. So Jesus says that he
we can ask him things while he's in
heaven and then also he's going to
answer our prayers. You'll find that in
John chapter 14. Okay. If you ever read
the gospel.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. Good question, man.
>> All right. Be please be safe, man. Be
careful
>> coming through, man.
>> Yeah. Good job, guys.
>> 67. Yes, sir.
>> Oh, come on.
>> That's his name. Oh, is it really?
[laughter]
>> Be careful.
>> Be careful, man.
>> We already folks.
>> Ah, [clears throat] good kids, man. They
um
>> given time, man. They they they will
really get their thoughts going, their
gears running. Um it's it's really crazy
the attitude that the kids have versus
the older ones, the adults. These kids,
you could talk to them, they listen.
They're not interrupting you. They, you
know, are polite and peaceful. The
adults are emotional. The adults are uh
belligerent and flamboyant. Well, that
tells you that that stuff is taught. So,
one of these days, hopefully, for God
forbid, but one of these days, if these
kids stay in this environment, they're
going to grow up just like their
counterparts. So, we're praying that the
seed is planted and that God does a
miracle work in their hearts. Um, it's
good that they saw us today. They they
will never forget this. We just read,
baby.
It's God. [music] It's God.